[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons parler de l'actualité
notamment des quartiers difficiles mais
surtout des solutions qui existent dans
les quartiers difficiles et qui sont
organisées par un certain nombre de
maires doit on parler aussi de politique
de la campagne électorale avec un
certain nombre de candidats qui se dira
peut-être des des balles dans le pied
certainement à gauche peut-être
peut-être à droite et puis on parlera
aussi de la situation sanitaire opposant
cette question faut-il confiner les non
vaccinés pour tous ces sujets catherine
arenou bonjour vous êtes la maire de
chanteloup les vignes vous êtes aussi la
présidente d'activité qui s'occupe de
l'emploi notamment cerciat sert de
l'association d'aidé dans les quartiers
difficiles et vous faites partie de ce
conseil national des solutions dont on
parlera dans quelques instants justement
qui c'est qui s'intéressent à ces
quartiers de la politique de la ville
jean charles lajoie dit bonjour bonjour
vous êtes toujours éditeurs toujours et
d'eux mêmes pascal jaouen public et vous
voilà parce qu'il révèle plus chez nous
une durée c'est assez rare un polar
assez peu c'est un polar et c'est un
polar dans une langue très très verte
info maîtriser son auto news
c'est bien c'est oui c'était très
marrant très drôle et ça se passe à la
ddt en normandie à rouen très bien ah
oui c'est très amusant geoffrey meyer
bonjour mon avocat au barreau de
versailles et secrétaire de la
conférence du stage toujours réellement
est toujours actuellement et quant à des
mères bonjour vous êtes toujours
étudiants mais aussi conseiller
municipal de wii en cours poursuit
mutuel le pcf voilà alors et pardon et
vincent couronne
vincent couronne un dîner hier avec jean
castex et voilà pourquoi il reste
c'est la version officielle cette
version officielle je vais sans crainte
vous êtes vous êtes docteur en droit
vous êtes enseignant journaliste et vous
êtes le fondateur des surligneurs à ce
groupe qui teste les idées notamment
répondu en politique pour voir si elles
sont applicables ou pas
exactement bonjour à tous
on va aux vacances n'est pas le premier
sujet je voudrais qu'on revienne sur sur
ce conseil national des solutions ça va
être le premier thème de cette émission
[Musique]
alors il faut dire il ya quatre ans il
ya eu un appel qui sape les appels de
grigny qui était lancée par une centaine
de maires dont vous étiez c'était quoi
cet appel de gagny
attiré l'attention du gouvernement
après ce qu'on a appelé l'été meurtrier
2017 où il y avait diminution importante
des apl est vrai une diminution très
importante des financements de la
politique de la ville appelé l'attention
du gouvernement sur nos quartiers sur et
sur l'idée qu'il fallait de nouveau
ni un vaste plan la cohésion de
l'ensemble des acteurs pour retrouver un
petit peu de vie dans nos quartiers puis
surtout pour essayer de les sortir de
ces situations que nous maires ne
considérant pas comme définitif luan là
et donc ça a commencé en 2010 est
l'appel borloo la loi borloo les textes
vers le haut tout le monde s en souvient
tout le monde se souvient aussi de la
façon dont la poubelle a récupéré le
dossier et puis il ya eu
un temps plus ou moins mort avec
quelques reprises de d'un certain nombre
de nos préconisations citerai par
exemple cité éducative mais pas que mais
d'une façon assez discrète et puis de
nouveau l'appel de 200 maires ça c'était
l'année dernière au mois de novembre et
l'idée c'était de dire plan de relance
massif pour la france tout à fait
d'accord mais on sait très bien nous
parce qu'on en a l'habitude que si on ne
cible pas particulièrement les actions
sur nos quartiers et bien les habitants
des quartiers ne bénéficieront pas de ce
plan de relance donc donc une
mobilisation massive et puis quelques
attentions et de la haie et tout ça
c'est une façon de penser c'est une
nouvelle façon de faire est de tout ça
on nous sommes quelques-uns association
mère avoir décidé d'inverser le
fonctionnement est de dire on n'attend
plus que sa nouvelle salle du haut on
montre parce que vous savez plus on est
en situation difficile puis on a d'une
intelligence collective et on a du
savoir faire collectif et qu'on montre
qu'il ya un certain nombre de solutions
qui marchent sur certains quartiers que
les maires eux mêmes
accompagne et qu'il faudrait qu'il doit
être regardé un peu avec une vision plus
nationale c'est à dire ceux qui marchent
à un endroit précis on sait évaluer
déclinons le différemment d'où ce
conseil national des solutions celui ci
va c'est à dire des solutions qui sont
déjà expérimentés dans un certain nombre
de villes qui peut être expérimenté un
peu partout et qui aux fauves ont
peut-être influencer la valeur
universelle le poteau de plus que le
savoir faire entre nous et les habitudes
entre nous de partager de partager ses
ces petites ou moyennes solutions qui
marchent fait naturellement nous les
déclinant de ville en ville entre amis
entre associatif qui se connaissent
voilà et donc ce conseil national
d'évolution c'est ça c'est on arrête de
la sphère politique faire de la
politique qui tombent du haut en bas on
s'aperçoit que quel que soit le
territoire et quelques sons et ventura
sa difficulté il ya des solutions
intelligentes qui sortent mais qui
viennent de cette intelligence
collective
d'absolument vouloir vous le voir faire
du positif sur nos quartiers et notre
premier sujet ça a été le sport alors le
sujet au vrai parce qu'on a quand même
été témoin on l'a vu très récemment que
le sport 2024 c'est à dire un dans deux
ans ça va être ça va être ce qui peut
fédérer voilà les géo tout ce qui peut
fédérer la france il faut surtout pas
alors que on a quand même été témoin
qu'un certain nombre de nos grands
champions sont ici nos quartiers il faut
surtout pas que toute cette énergie
autour du sport des jo-2000 24 passe
encore à côté de nos quartiers
populaires et donc l'idée du sport au
service de la république c'est
accrochons cette formidable événement et
faisons ensemble un projet porté par les
quartiers qui bénéficie à tous mais
surtout aux habitants de quartiers et
c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi les valeurs du
poste et elle travaille à la
persévérance il ya pas du tout dans la
solidarité dans le sport élitiste il
fallait le giro mais pas du tout non
c'est quelque chose qu'on essaye de ne
pas de ne pas décliner chez nous non non
on n'est pas dans un sport élitiste on
est dans les valeurs du sport et qui
peuvent se décliner à tous les atouts
les temps de la vie on est très attentif
il faut par exemple remettre le sport à
l'école le sport à l'école c'est un
parent pauvre or il ya du savoir faire
sur nos territoires siviriez du salvan
faire d'enseignants mais pas que il ya
du savoir faire de nos éducateurs
sportifs il ya du savoir-faire des
associations sportives et personne ne se
met autour de la table pour donner à ce
temps élémentaires du temps avec la
valeur sport sur lesquels non moi je
suis persuadé puisqu'on le voit très
régulièrement un gamin qui a des
difficultés scolaires il peut être un
parfait un sportif qui se et du coup ils
ne se regardent pas il n'est pas
regardée par les autres de la même façon
si le voilà le faso de
tous les âges parce que c'est aussi la
façon de vivre à aix encore à la fois
qu'on soit tous petits ou qu'on soit
seniors le sport c'est aussi une autre
façon de ceux de ce mouvoir et puis nous
on y tient beaucoup c'est le sport
insertion on est quelques territoires y
est je vous en ai déjà parlé ici on est
quelques territoires avoir développé
avec le département ce qu'on appelle les
coaches d'insertion et c'est la même
chose quand on est adolescent qu'on est
un peu paumé qu'on n'a pas de qu'on ne
sait pas vers quel emploi allez on est
con décline du sport parce qu'on fait
partie d'un club est bien tous les
éducateurs sportifs de ce club et des
nouveaux métiers qui sont des coachs
d'insertion par le sport peuvent vous
faire décliner ses compétences que vous
êtes capable de développer dans le sport
et voulait faire décliner vers un emploi
et un emploi durable et là vous êtes
reconnu ça marche on est quelques villes
à avoir depuis deux ans a porté ce
dispositif le département le soutien ça
existe maintenant dans plane département
et on sait que c'est à la fois un
nouveau métier et une nouvelle façon de
faire de l' approche vers l'emploi pas
relaté milliards d'us ferrari et tout ça
est lié 1 il ya beaucoup notamment de
deux jours
après je vous en ai pas parlé mais
évidemment le sport ça se fait
obligatoirement et des structures
sportives du dimanche faut décliner plus
de choses qu'elle quand on fait un club
de belote on est d'accord mais néanmois
on peut aussi avoir cette intelligence
de partage et on s'aperçoit qu'ils
avaient un certain de fédération qui
maintenant sont capables de développer
des nouveaux lieux de sport avec
beaucoup moins de demandes de moyens et
beaucoup plus de solutions de partage et
ça aussi on est aussi dans une espèce
d'économie de et d'économie de
structures c'est à la fois faire des
complexes faire des endroits où on peut
faire du sport certains sports le
réclament et puis savoir partagé sur
certains spas les dodgers c'est cette
volonté de la fédération c'est pour ça
qu'on a travaillé avec la fédération de
judo c'est la capacité de mettre dans
plein de lieux
la proche du judo et ne pas attendre
qu'on pense pas qu'on construise un
énorme complexe sportif mais on peut le
faire dans des rez-de-chaussée de
l'immeuble on peut le faire on l'a on
peut le faire à plein d'endroits et on
peut surtout partager ces lieux et ses
1000 dojo c'est aussi la façon
d'accueillir le fait de faire connaître
une nouvelle discipline chez nos jeunes
puisque c'est aussi un des sujets de nos
de nos quartiers c'est qu'en fait ils
sont tournés vers 2 3 sport mais pas
tous et on a le devoir de leur faire
connaître plein de sports mais c'est
aussi la capacité de les accueillir par
l'intermédiaire justement il ya des
éducateurs qui viennent par
l'intermédiaire de ce qu'on peut
décliner dans le judo et de les faire à
me les a menés aussi vers l'emploi et
vous avez été entendu par l'état puisque
non non on parle de la création de cinq
mille 5000 équipements de natation 200
millions de petits peu entendu parler tu
as juste avant ce conseil national des
solutions puisque effectivement se
déclinent des des moyens pour faire des
terrains de sport de proximité
donc ça c'est la première chose parce
que tous ces territoires en ont besoin
mais vous avez vu que ce n'est pas le
seul les seuls lieux qui sont importants
c'est aussi l'accompagnement oui c'est
aussi l'accompagnement et il faut dire
que oui c'est un travail formidable des
maires lors vous êtes tous des mères
c'est formidable dans cette association
mais y'a aussi par b vous un qui était
qui était élue meilleure bière du monde
et on n'en est pas fière
parce qu'il dit bien lui-même qu'en fait
il alors ses filets prio maire de grigny
et il dit bien que c'est en tant que
maire de banlieue en tant que maire de
banlieue
il a été reconnu meilleur maire du monde
mais on est c'est vrai qu'on est assez
fier parce que c'est aussi tout le
travail de ces mères de proximité qui
salue une
organisation internationale mais c'est
tout c'est ma de banlieue qui s'appuie
sur le territoire le terrain associatif
sur les habitants pour essayer de faire
avancer un peu nos quartiers et leurs
habitants et ça c'est vrai que c'est une
nouvelle peut être content vous êtes
qu'il nous conseil municipal ces cinq
ans je peux être que fier que ce soit
philippe riou qui soit et l'univers donc
un maire communiste en plus même si y'a
pas que les maires communistes qui ont
reconnus dans leur travail notamment les
quartiers populaires merkel c'est vrai
que c'est d'ordre dans ses luxueux
conseil national des solutions on trouve
des maires de toutes tendances
politiques car c'est presque un rythme
presque oui bahreïn
les contrer
ça que je pense que derrière philippe
riou et aussi toute une tradition alors
c'est vrai qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans
les mouvements socialistes et
communistes ce qu'on appelait le
socialisme municipal le communisme
municipal et après que d'autres mais
rossi se sont approprié ce le fait que
la mairie reste une entité très
importante du service public et qu'on
apporte beaucoup service public elle aux
populations à travers aussi le soutien
aux associations à travers la de
vacances à travers plein d'ados qui
était cité en tout cas avant que l'état
le lait prénommant et donc du coup c'est
vraiment cette idée je le trouve de
mettre en avant l'audace des maires
locaux laurent leur envie de faire et
quand ils ont les moyens de faire ils
peuvent faire des choses incroyables et
ça que moi j'ai envie de dire aussi il
faut l'état dans sa relation avec les
collectivités y restent y aurait un
petit problème actuellement c'est que si
la tendance quand même imposer
l'austérité aux collectivités a passé
toujours plus en plus vers les appels à
projets et à mettre sous tutelle petit à
petit le lait le budget des
collectivités j'ai envie de dire à
l'état il faut la confiance il faut de
la confiance et donc il faut redonner du
budget aux collectivités et du budget
qui soit pas forcément contraint fléché
pas appel à projets qui peut organiser
mais qui donne par là par la dotation la
dgf ce qu'on appelle du bli le nom ces
dotations globales de fonctionnement
plus aux collectivités pour qu'elles
puissent d'elle-même en fonction de leur
territoire agir au plus près et c'est
pour voir une nouvelle répartition enfin
c'est pas du pouvoir enfin en tout cas
des initiatives si c'était vrai aussi
avec la crise sanitaire on a vu comment
les maires se sont emparés
parfois des manques de l'état ou des
difficultés d'état ou des lourdeurs de
d'état pour pour agir là c'est pareil
dans l'est dans les quartiers c'est un
peu ça aussi
dans son discours à la mfr monsieur
laignel a dit une chose très évidente
pendant le temps du coni de l'état fait
ce qu'il pouvait et les maires ont fait
le reste c'est exactement ça parce qu'en
fait il y avait d'abord parce que tout
le monde était tétanisé devant cette
nouvelle situation et puis parce que
c'était c'était une suite de difficultés
individuelles et qui voit mieux les
difficultés individuelles qu'en fait que
les acteurs de locaux à la fois les
associations qui sur laquelle on a
beaucoup avec laquelle on a beaucoup
travaillé puis les maires et tous les
maires ont retroussé les manches et ont
été avec leurs élus et tous leurs élus
pour aller au plus près de ses
difficultés parce que le temps que le
temps que les dispositifs nationaux
retombe sur les territoires c'était donc
ça a été deux ou trois mois et deux ou
trois mois cette loi de grande précarité
de grandes difficultés et mais c'est
vraiment on a vu le coc vite ça a été ça
avait été une évaluation en temps réel
de ce qu'on était tous capables de faire
ou de ne pas faire et d'une façon
générale sont possibles sur ce sujet
c'est vrai que on voit que l'importance
de ce qui se passe sur le terrain
maintenant face ça prend une importance
veut c'est vrai que on attend plutôt de
diou du sommet de l'état et c'est parce
que quand même un progrès même si
parfois on n'est plus dans la
déconcentration de la décentralisation
c'est un terreau proche pour faire
emmanuel m'incomber mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est une nouvelle façon
de gouverner peut-être de comprendre les
réalités de ce que vivent les français
la tude rose
tout ce qu'a dit madame était frappée au
coin du bon sens comme on dit souvent
que l'on veut pas la seule chose qui
même m'étonne un peu c'est le slogan le
sport au service de la république mon
patron
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je ne
comprends pas du tout mais pas au
service de tous aux services légaux mais
le forces armées de la république
fonctionne super bien
sûr que les valeurs en sport mesure les
valeurs par exemple avec les jeux
olympiques enfin c'est aussi une fin des
jeux olympiques c'est aussi une chance
pour les quartiers pour l'heure bleue
pour le fait que tout le monde aille un
peu dans le même sens pour la solidarité
pour l'effort pour le placer n'ont cessé
toutes les valeurs républicaines à la
fois les valeurs d'équité républicaine
de fraternité n'est pas ludique le son
n'est pas républicain c'est
la formulation que ce sont bien le sport
au sol des quelque chose d'élitiste
parfois dans le sport qui pourrait
qu'ils pourraient en effet être être
contre les valeurs républicaines
d'égalité mais on va pas faire des
vagues voilà que vincent vincent pour
vous les intervenants au débat
philosophique sur le valeurs du sport
alors est ce que le sport le sport est
certainement républicain est ce que la
république et sportives c'est peut-être
encore le tuner je pense la réplique
française et manque peut-être un petit
peu de d'appétence pour le sport est bon
je veux pas me lancer dans ce débat là
mais en tout cas sur le pouvoir
grandissant des maires je pense que il y
a quand même alors oui il ya eu des
vagues décentralisation donc c'est
normal que que que le cul que le maire
en fait soit plus comment dire et plus
de pouvoir aujourd'hui qu'il n'en avait
auparavant même si effectivement tout ça
est à relativiser parce que ces
décentralisations sont souvent en fait à
ces contraintes
pour les mères mais je pense qu'un des
éléments central de ces dernières années
et de ces derniers mois même qui montre
peut-être
plus les mères ou qui les met plus en
avant c c'est par exemple des éléments
comme le plan de relance et le conseil
national des souris et si on le monde
c'est-à-dire cas partout où l'état
dépense énormément pour soutenir
l'investissement y compris dans les
collectivités etc et bien les maires
s'organisent pour pouvoir capter une
partie de ceux de ses financements là
donc c'est pas anormal aussi qu'on voit
qu'on voit aujourd'hui des alliances de
mer ce soit sur du conseil national de
la solution que ce soit les maires aussi
qu'ils ont fait naître de soutien
immédiat de macron il ya quelques jours
et c'est donc c'est pas
voilà je pense qu'il ya la question
financière aussi qui n'est pas très
éloigné de ceux de ce cette meilleure
visibilité des maires aujourd'hui et
c'est tant mieux probablement un mot
là-dessus on peut passer au aussi juste
suivre oui oui gandalf à la fois il a
contrainte pour moi financière qui fait
que à relativiser dans le pouvoir des
maires tu es aussi la question des
intercommunalités ou finalement les
maires qui sont pourtant les preuves en
première ligne ont pas forcément autant
de pouvoir alors surtout quand on est
minoritaire dans l'agglomération
oui on aimerait pouvoir travailler sur
un plan d'équité entre tous les
différents maires et défendre les maires
d'opposition et le mr de huy au contrat
et vice-président de la wii la vie de
l'ex président ça veut dire que c'est le
travail au mieux ça pour autant qu'on
veut ainsi être
toujours une opposition
sceptique sauf que sauf que le maire
haussier est élu dans sa ville qu'il est
aussi légitime dans sa ville il faudrait
aussi qu'ils aient du pouvoir c'est vrai
et le conseil national des solutions de
proue c'est que bas il ya un certain
nombre de solutions qui dépasse les
clivages politiques wade voit la chose
comme de bon sens et puis je pense qu'il
faut changer là faut changer le propos
les maires ne cherche pas à avoir du
pouvoir ils cherchent à avoir la liberté
d'agir et c'est pas du tout la même
chose et il ne cherche pas toujours des
moyens financiers que la capacité de
pouvoir faire et je pense que si on
reste toujours dans cette définition de
le maire veut le pouvoir le maire veut
de l'argent non seulement on va un peu
lassé les concitoyens mais en plus on
est on ne les fera pas adhéré vers une
nouvelle façon de prendre de prendre son
destin en main de ces sites d'après ce
qu'on cherche accompagnant les
associations qui prennent déjà leur
destin en main pour porter un certain
nombre de valeurs et d'avancer pour nos
habitants pensent qu'il faut il faut il
faut inverser la la la façon de penser y
compris pour les intercommunalités les
intercommunalités ce groupe machin
effectivement quai entre qui est entre
la ville et le département eh ben ce
second match et nous en sommes tous
responsables parce que nous en sommes
tous des acteurs donc à un moment donné
on ne peut plus continuer peut pas
toujours continuer à dire que les
intercommunalités
elle et nous ne nous sommes qu'est ce
que nous en faisons et comment on
répartit les différentes capacités
d'agir
était de défendre pour moi l'intérêt
général du territoire avant des fois
d'être dans une logique politicienne il
faut il faudrait vraiment qu'on puisse
travailler globalement sur tous les
sujets dans l'intérêt général dans
l'intérêt de nos citoyens qu'est-ce que
soit le leur a blessé c'est de toute
façon pour tenir un propos assez concis
c'est la grande spécificité des mères en
réalité vous êtes beaucoup plus porté
par une action que par une doctrine sur
un maire c'est davantage ancrée sur ce
qui va se passer dans son territoire que
propre à porter la parole d'un parti qui
finalement a un aspect plus centralisée
et qui se répercute beaucoup moins
aisément sur le territoire vous êtes
beaucoup plus en marge de ces de ces
combats politiciens vous ce qui vous
intéresse c'est l'action et c'est ce qui
se passe quotidiennement dans vos
communes et c'est vrai que la france
c'est à la fois une centralisation mais
c'est surtout des spécificités
territoriales et ça c'est vous qui
l'incarné le mieux
quelles que soient les courants
politiques et au delà mail et au delà
même
on va passer peut-être à la campagne
électorale mais on va rester le meilleur
puisque les u7 cette élection du nouveau
président de l'association des maires de
france
[Musique]
oui et deux événements qui concerne
l'amérique sont peut-être lié
probablement lié à la campagne
électorale via l'élection de
l'association des maires de france 2
avec 10 9 le maire de cannes qui était l
air qui était le successeur de françois
baroin était jusque là le président qui
a été élu cotre
mère qui s'appelle monsieur laurent
qui étaient dix dont on disait qu'il
était le candidat des manuels macro on a
dit
nettement plus macron compatible que
c'est à dire qu'elle maniait marrant
c'est la première fois que je vois dans
une assemblée que le président félicite
plus le perdant que père d'accueil
gagnant mais bon ce qui quand même à
laisser des traces c'est assez sportif
et pendant cette partie
c'est une victoire assez à ses dettes de
david lisnard
maintenant il ya quand même 13 personnes
de la liste de selon qu'ils rentrent
dans les instances nationales de la meuf
donc il ya aussi un équilibre qui joue
dans tout ça va se calmer faut pas
oublier que c'est pas seulement un
président qui est élu la mfc ac 1 c'est
un groupe c'est à la fois un bureau et
un comité directeur dont vous verrez que
toutes les sensibilités sont représentés
naturellement et ça depuis des années
donc ça va se décliner un peu
différemment enfin je pense que très
rapidement tout le monde
livre à une espèce de consensus
d'ailleurs le
traditionnellement le premier prise dès
la première prise de parole juste avant
la parole du président de la république
est généralement voté par l'ensemble du
comité directeur ça a été voté à
l'unanimité sert le propos de monsieur
daniel a été votée à l'unanimité sa vie
voilà c'est ça donc ça veut dire que
déjà les maires sont capables d'avoir
d'avoir de savoir parler d'une façon un
peu uniforme en tout cas lorsqu'il
s'agit de défendre les intérêts de leurs
habitants est ce important
d'associer son bref serre c'est très
important de se retrouver de partager
d'être accompagné d'être formé avec mr
s'est malheureusement c'est une fonction
et ça devient un métier mais il faut
aussi qu'on soit en capacité de partager
on est très fermé de formidablement
accompagner dans les formations dans les
partages de les partager à la fois de le
savoir de quelques fois des espérances
et quelquefois aussi de 2,2 bagarre
voilà c'est les maires sont aussi là
pour temps en temps faire entendre leur
voix et toutes les associations de
maires celles qui sont généralistes
comme les meufs qui représente quand
même énormément de mer comme celles qui
sont spécialisés sur des territoires
parce que moi je suis vice président de
l'association villes et banlieues qui
dit bien son nom elles ont elles ont
cette capacité à faire affaire à
accompagner tous les maires dans leur
exercice au quotidien est alors dans le
même temps ou juste après en tout cas il
ya eu un appel qui était dans l'équipe
aille dans le jdd de 600 berre
dont christian estrosi mais doit aussi
de sur le territoire karl olive
ou arnaud péricard à soutenir emmanuel
macron pour un deuxième mandat il doit
philippe évidemment mais ça c'était moi
et non
est ce que les maires vont peser dans la
dans la campagne électorale on parlait
tout à l'heure des territoires c'est
intéressant parce que est ce que
justement les territoires vont peser
dans cette campagne électorale votre
avis le jour donnera la parole après
mais
je pense que oui en tout cas c'est
important pour un candidat à la
présidence alors futile le président
sortant ou futiles un autre candidat
d'avoir le soutien des maires parce que
ça rejoint finalement ce que je vous
disais précédemment ce qui montre que je
reste un petit peu cohérent dans mes
propos c'est important
c'est que en réalité les mères étant le
les hommes de territoire et d'action
savoir qu'un président peut compter sur
cette base enfin qu'un candidat peut
compter sur cette base ça me semble être
politiquement très important et aussi
étant donné que parfois vous sortez même
de cette coloration politique un
président qui peut avoir le soutien de
personnes qui n'ont pas justement une
coloration spécifique politique
finalement c'est être assimilée soi même
à des personnes à des hommes et des
femmes d'action et ça je pense que pour
un décisionnaire politique ou un
candidat c'est extrêmement important
vous l'a décidé
mais il ya deux termes qui reviennent
dans le dans la tribune qui ont été
publiés c'est m2 d'un lien de confiance
qui s'était établi avec le avec le prix
de la république et c'est aussi l'idée
qu' il faut un temps long pour faire des
choses
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient réagir ce
deux arguments mais non mais je pense
que on a tous voila donc c'est c'est une
décision de 600 mères on est dans une
campagne présidentielle oui mais je
pense qu'on a tous surtout avec les
associations dont on fait partie on a
tous à interpeller l'ensemble des
candidats sur un certain nombre de
d'action et de relation voilà si on
interpelle tous les candidats je pense
que moi à titre personnel la plus grande
prudence et de ne pas c'est de ne pas
s'afficher pour l'instant parce qu'il
faut parce qu'il faut absolument
interpeller tous les candidats en tout
cas sur les sur les banlieues pour pour
des prises de position elle peut faire
et le président de la république et
actuel s'il est un candidat il y aura
effectivement aussi répondre à certains
de l'interpellation de beaucoup
d'associations d'élus assez classique ça
barde ont
beaucoup des signataires sont quand même
très macro compatible enfin je deviens
ils sont tous il ya pas l air voilà il
n'ya pas une surprise politique énorme
on dire à retiers ils ont signé pour le
choisir macron voilà on s'y attendait un
peu ctc
travail allemand est fort c'est très
bien de le faire non mais c'est tout à
leur honneur j'ai beau et c'est très
important pour le président macro qui
est quand même très maline ces domaines
dont la république mars est très très
mal
oui santé reproche qu'on lui faisait
beaucoup c'est n'a jamais avoir eu un
poste électif avant de devenir président
d'être rapport soldes être coupé des
réalités et la brouille cdh mr dix
grands il ya eu une relation de
confiance qui s'était établi un peu avec
le avec l'otan c'était une prise de
position politique évidemment de l'arpa
c'est quand même un caillou de plus dans
la chaussure des républiques
vincent là dessus
je je vais comment dire sortir un petit
peu mon joker parce que je trouve que
c'est une question très politique et
pardon vous pouvez
c'est une question très politique est là
dessus moi comme je m'exprime en tant
que juriste ici je sais pas si j'ai
grand chose à dire sur ces questions là
sauf que les maires enfin la mf
effectivement mais ça a déjà été dit
joue un rôle essentiel pour la formation
des maires et leur accompagnement et je
pense que la solitude dans laquelle sont
beaucoup de maires l'impréparation aussi
dans laquelle ils peuvent être et en
même temps ils veulent tous bien faire
un bien évidemment la ms se joue un rôle
absolument essentiel pour les former et
les accompagner ça je trouve que c'est
c'est déjà une chose qui est absolument
essentiel vous sied tout ce que je dirai
d'accord quant à vous avec les maires
interviennent beaucoup dans la
présidentielle ce qui est bien avec les
maires c'est qu'en général il parle des
vrais sujets des sujets réels et son
mandant des dents dans des attaques
politiciennes qui sont très très heureux
très déconnecté des réalités des
français donc si les élus peuvent
apporter des vrais sujets au coeur des
problématiques des gens c'est toujours
plus bénéfique que
débord ce va parler peut-être des dll
puisque vous disiez avec c'était un
caillou et chaussures des délais c'est
vrai qu'on a en a on a vu des débats des
jarres et 3 de trois débats
une sensibilité de semble-t-il très à
droite mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
convaincre les adhérents de l air
valérie pécresse a fait 1 un meeting au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ils ont fait un sondage auprès d une
information été fait auprès des gens qui
y assister et on leur demandait quels
sont les trois thèmes que keith wood
paraissent essentiels la premier set et
d'immigration deuxième la sécurité
troisième l'islamisation
c'est quand même c'est presque étonnant
non il n'ya pas le fait pas l'économie
le ça nous étonne pas un bâtiment vous
sélectionnez votre nouveau les gens que
vous questionnez fatalement vous avez
dit vous avez
puis voilà quels sont les tranches d'âge
d'où vient-il ce qui m'intéresse moi
c'est de savoir non c'est pas de savoir
ces deux c'est d'arriver à c'est
d'arriver à ramener les français vers
vers autre chose
que les débats actuels c'est à dire
parce que la réalité c'est ça c'est
quand même le pouvoir d'achat c'est
quand même la capacité de projeter ses
enfants vers autre chose et vers plus
que ce qu'on a fait c'est l'éducation il
ya quand même des vrais thèmes qui qui
peuvent qui sont complètement
républicain qui peuvent nous rassembler
puisque les thèmes qui nous sont donnés
actuellement dans les médias donc
j'espère qu'on aura la capacité
collective de faire remonter le niveau
c'est après une fois qu'il y aura un
candidat désigné il va falloir non plus
s'adresser aux militants l air mais tout
le monde et ça change peut-être le
discours d'hier non c'est peut-être les
thèmes qui nous sont imposées en ce
moment sont peut-être aussi dû à cette
période de flottement où on n'a pas
encore l'intégralité des candidats qui
sont déclarés qui du coup un rose qui
impose certains thèmes parce que les
médias aiment aussi à les relayer mais
lorsque ils seront tous candidats a
déclaré un moment ils vont devoir aussi
être confronté à la réalité du programme
qu'ils vont vouloir mettre en place
derrière et l'a peut-être en tout cas
c'est le souhait à votre instar que je
formule aussi que les thèmes
bascule un petit peu plus sur des choses
beaucoup plus réaliste beaucoup plus
concrète beaucoup plus prégnante et
beaucoup plus nécessaire par rapport aux
enjeux que de notre société qui vont
être venir dans les dix prochaines
années je suppose que c'est pas il dort
et d'avoir quand même des sondages on
est
d'abord de penser que les médias
imposerait de toutes pièces des thèmes
de
discussion réflexion mais je pense que
c'est réussir avec les délateurs et
surtout on sait sur ton accord avec ce
que pensent beaucoup de gens en france
aient quand madame de s'occuper de
l'avenir de nos jeunes est-ce que l'on
s'occupe en de la viande de nos jeunes
on peut faire l'impasse sur le débat sur
l'islamisme je veux moi je ne crois pas
je veux ça me parait intimement liés je
veux dire l'avenir de la france c'est
aussi de traiter et de promettre un
mouchoir ou la poussière sous le tapis
en revenant milices la mise au rebut on
n'en parle pas il ya plus important que
le pouvoir d'achat non moi je pense que
c'est plus important de savoir comment
la république qui vous est cher ce qui
est de sport et d'islamisme voilà je
pense que c'est indispensable et que de
dire non non c'est pas le sujet il faut
il faut en revenir à duch et
non mais personne ne dit c'est pas le
sujet
il y en a d'autres sujets mais pourquoi
on arrivait à d'autres sujets on a parlé
de priorité est-ce que la priorité
des disques en solitaire 10 bat la
priorité des gens c'est peut-être pas
celle là mais il faudra aussi la
sécurité c'est pas
que ce soit de sujets qu'ils puissent
tout à fait coexister dans le cadre
d'une coexistence campagne au cou avec
ans avec en réalité la même importance
simplement que des sujets qui à mon avis
en ce moment il n'existe pas plus
émerger dans le débat public dans le
cadre de l'élection présidentielle sans
que pour autant sa relève ceux qui sont
exposés en ce moment à un second plan
que cette coexistence à nous écrit droit
de nous en savons comment les débats il
faut aussi de ne pas perdre de vue que
économiquement il n'y a pas un papier à
cigarette entre les républicains
emmanuel macron donc il ya de quoi de
quoi pourrait-il parler comment
peuvent-ils essayer de se différencier
du président qui vont faire la même
politique la majorité le premier
ministre et tissent de fin est issu de
leurs rangs le précédent premier
ministre était issu de leurs rangs les
ministres sont issus de leur range
derrière calais 10 ans c'est pas sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui vont se différencier
c'est pas sur l'économie c'est pas sur
le affectivement le
diana qui nous parle des aliens oui
c'était c'était une bonne idée donc
voila mais sinon
sur l'économie contre un but pareil il
ya une question politique en effet qui
est celle de la désignation du candidat
de la droite républicaine qui se fait de
vous encourez de militants c'est vrai
que par nature et les militants sont
toujours
la droite que l'électorat donc il faut
s'adresser d'abord à eux après il va
falloir faire une sorte de grand écart
impôts pour s'adresser enfin la foule à
recentrer la campagne comme on disait
c'est un peu ça le la technique
du ministre le prochain premier ministre
c'est tout peut-être que c'est une
sollicitation qui va être élu ce sera
vincent et là dessus voilà peut-être
vous voulez qu'on parle de l'europe
oui oui on peut mais juste un mot sur la
question de l'ordination par les
primaires là la désignation par les
primaires elle par définition en fait
elle comment dire elle aboutit quasiment
systématiquement à désigner des
candidats qui ne sont pas qui sont les
candidats d'un parti d militant du parti
et pas des candidats qui sont amenés
forcément à
recueillir le plus de voix au sein de la
population donc on voit que la primaire
afin de tout un tas de mécanismes de
primes et avons échoué de ces dernières
années est celui des républiques celle
des républicains
connaîtra peut-être le même sort c'est
effectivement la personne qui est
désigné n'est pas en mesure de bien à la
fois s'adresser là comme elle le fait
maintenant assez à ses militants qui
sont effectivement souvent non plus à
droite que l'ensemble de la france
évidemment c'est le paysage politique
est comme ça et s'adressaient aussi en
même temps l'ensemble des français une
fois que la primaire la primaire sera
terminé ça c'est un grand écart qui sera
pas facile à faire et cela dit vous avez
raison de rappeler parce que là on dit
c'est le sait les militants du parti
mais si on prend les primaires de 2016 à
droite notamment l on qualifie françois
fillon qui était plutôt le candidat le
plus à droite de l'échiquier un devoir
d'aider des représentants or c'était pas
que les militants qui s'exprime et c'est
ce qui me gêne un peu c'est que c'est
c'est dans les propos qu'on entende
l'impression que vous êtes militant ce
serait une tare moi je trouve ça très
bien et
très bien notre ami par exemple soient
militants c'est courageux et les
militants et délégués sont les opposants
sociologique 6ème position
usa baptisant et à une prise de position
plus ferme d'un côté et de l'autre
se trouve que c'est très bien de
missions imparties plein jour à dire
mais oui les gens s'intéressent plus les
gens consentants ce sera aux militants
et ben c'est très bien quand un mec je
partage pas les îles notre ami musique
merveilleux
et justement moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
un peu de me dire c'est quand même
triste que dans une droite qui se dit
républicaine les sujets qui leur importe
le plus c'est encore une fois
l'immigration c'est encore une fois des
questions comme ça va on a beaucoup
parlé de gaulle il ya quelques semaines
je crois pas que dans le gaullisme on
retienne du gaullisme la lutte contre
l'immigration aux choses comme ça on
retient une droite qui était un malaise
social
que quoi ce que s'il avait été s'il
avait été pour l'algérie française ils
rêvent beaucoup une vague d'immigration
etc
c'était avant tout une droite qui se
préoccupe ce qu'ils sont mais la
question sociale aussi qui s'occupait du
travail après les périodes chance c'est
c'était le compromis là près de l'après
guerre entre gaullistes et communistes
on avait une frange sociale qu'elle est
construite et moi j'ai envie de rappeler
un petit peu ce brame du cerf est
rappelé à la droite il ya eu le cnr que
c'était un bon programme que c'était le
moment où la france a des résistants et
6 et 6 est 6ème devant la française y
sommes si c'est vraiment la france je
pense qu'il faudrait revenir sur sur les
grands principes et d'ailleurs c'est
marrant ce que dans cette droite là et
beaucoup de droite extrêmement libérale
il ya une droite qui a cassé beaucoup
les jeux de famille de la france en
privatisant beaucoup de tact et de
beaucoup d'activités en voulant
criminaliser toujours les plus pauvres
en voulant criminaliser l'immigré là où
les belles le vrai problème sont pas là
donc j'aimerais qu'ils retournent un
petit os docteur la
déco si elle aimerait voir la vie c'est
comme dire pour moi qu'on combatte
l'islamisme dans les quartiers s'associe
par plus de république dans les
quartiers ça passe par le sport comme on
l'a dit ça passe par l'éducation ça
passe par est une république qui prend
qui prend soin et qui est belle chance
elle passe peut-être par parce que on
parle beaucoup de l'immigration c'est
pas sûr que la question de l'immigration
sur une question centrale dans les airs
dans les chiffres mais peut-être que la
question de l'intégration
elle est une question beaucoup plus
forte et c'est vrai qu'elle ait laissé
un peu de côté parce que pour le
beaucoup de les disciples de
l'immigration qui n'ont pas y aller
froch et 30 mille trente mille personnes
immigrées peau de travail qui sont venus
en 2020 c'est pas énorme après c'est
comment les adresses et bleu de la vraie
question c'est celle là c'est peut-être
plutôt de celle de maintenant je voulais
me semble mais
du moment où un semblant de gens sautent
hors france en situation régulière
puisque à peu près tous d'accord pour
pour faire respecter la loi c'est de
dire quelle chanson leur dette est-ce
qu'on leur donne les mêmes chances que
causent haute et est ce qu'on les met
pas dans des situations tellement
compliqué qu'en fait on sait déjà qu'on
va contribuer à spontanément ce qu ils
ne s'intègrent pas est ce qu'il ne
réussisse pas d'enfant non plus et il ya
un sujet moi qui mets qui m'est
absolument sur lesquels je suis
absolument incontournable c'est le sujet
du peuplement parce que regarder ce que
fait la france moi je veux bien qu'on
crie concret maintenant à
alaa
sur l'immigration enfin vous dire c'est
que ce soit le sujet thème mais qu'est
ce qu'on a fait depuis des années que
les populations entre sur le territoire
d'une façon régulière mais quelle
qu'elle soit et c'est en ile-de-france
et particulier qu'elle soit toujours
concentré dans un certain secteur et
donc il ya une espèce de concentration à
domicile c'est quand même une politique
de peuplement qu'on n'a pas mené
correctement donc effectivement si vous
concentrer des précarités sur un
territoire fatalement vous aurez des
débordements si c'est trop compliqué à
gérer or ça fait quand il est arrivé et
je n y ai bien passé c'est pour ça
qu'elle
est une politique on sait très bien que
ces concentrations la pub doublement
fait qu'on est les seuls à essayer de
admettre de l'équité territoriale et de
l'équité de d'avenir et que mais que
l'état ne le fait pas donc regardons les
choses en face et puis essayons tête un
petit peu solidaires les uns des autres
parce que la solidarité et la prise en
charge de toutes les difficultés tous en
même temps je vais vous dire à certains
endroits on n'en serait pas où on en est
donc il faut peut-être regarder non pas
ce qu'on est capable de ne pas avoir
fait et se remettent en question nous
mêmes français c'est-à-dire l'état
français qu'est ce qu'il a fait qu'est
ce qu'il n'a pas fait et il ya des
choses qui sont quand même assez simple
et l'avenir pour l'instant personne n'en
parle de cette politique de peuplement
parce que traditionnellement moi j'ai le
sentiment que donc c'est
bien on peut en parler de loin mais on
peut accepter tout le monde accepte
d'une patte de ne pas prendre le sujet à
bras le corps or nous maires de terrain
on prend le sujet à bras le fil puisque
vous parliez justement de ce polymère
vous êtes arrivé à fait
évident mais c'est vrai qu'ils avaient
des concentrations de populations
incroyable flotte dans certains
quartiers il vous avez réussi à faire
regretter un peu ça
oui on a réussi à faire mais mais mais
regardez ce qu'on appelle la politique
de peuplement des attributions de
logements regardez qu'il dit que les
populations les plus précaires tout
préparé pour écarts étaient confondus à
la fois la pauvreté l'absence de
connaissance du français tout précarité
confondues regarder ce qui existe à bien
ça continue ils continuent à trouver du
logement social uniquement dans les
quartiers de logement social car les
quartiers les plus denses donc on n'en
sortira pas parce que on continuera à
faire prendre un fabre des risques à
tout le monde sur l'avenir donc
fatalement ne pas savoir gérer et ça
c'est plus possible
un maire de cette région ont failli à
quelques dix pas normal que dans des
collèges et dans des classes 70 % de
musulmans dans une classe c'est vrai que
je viens et sauf que moi ce que je dis
c'est quand j'ai 80 % de gens d'origine
étrangère quelle que soit l'origine est
d'origine étrangère et avec une
méconnaissance de la langue française
c'est en tant que maire c'est ça qui
m'importe c'est d'ailleurs c'est déjà on
l'aimé pas égalité de réussite
sur la primaire on à madame pécresse
madame pécresse qui doit toujours des
migrations nous parle immigration mais
en même temps celles qui défendent les
maires de droite qui ne respectent pas
la loi sru et qui du coup empêche cette
meilleure répartition à des populations
votre propre au
conseil départemental dans une partie
son parti républicain qu'est ce qu'on
fait on donne des moyens au maire qui
justement ne sont pas sont très loin de
là de respecter la loi sru pour pouvoir
respecter cette loi sru parce que il ya
aussi une volonté je vous accorde que
quelques maires ne sont pas volontaires
mais il ya aussi maintenant 2021 la
possibilité physique et la possibilité
financière donc à un moment donné faut
aussi donner des moyens pour que cette
loi soit respectée quand même 20 ans
après la sru donc salem mais que ça va
quand même tellement de temps à se
serrer un peu pas dire qu'ils étaient
plus pourra jouer les uns que les autres
le faire respecter
de toute façon je vous coupe la parole
parce que là il faut que partie remise
après très bien peu quentin et vincent à
l'atelier comparé à un mot peut-être
parce que pour éclairer un peu le débat
c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de
positions des candidats aient l'air sur
l'europe
sur la suprématie ou pas la suprématie
des traités européens sur les droits
internes sur sur les propositions
notamment de michel barnier
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer un
peu sur sur ce sujet
oui mais alors c'est un c'est un vaste
sujet patrice parce que effectivement
c'est que là on a
si vous avez deux heures devant vous on
peut on peut en parler
[Rires]
bon évidemment tout le monde voit que
c'est assez inédit que lors d'une
campagne présidentielle on parle autant
de primauté dans l'union européenne
comparé l'otan de ces questions devaient
d'identité constitutionnelles nationales
etc et donc de primauté du droit de
l'union qu'est-ce-qui ce qu'est ce qui
se passe je pense que chez les
républicains en particulier il y a
probablement la volonté de combler un
vide et notamment de récupérer des voix
à l'extrême droite que ce soit cette
marine le pen d'eric zemmour sur les
sujets justement les sujets européens
mais aussi parce que ce sont comment
dire exe mot aujourd'hui n'a pas
forcément beaucoup parlé sur les
questions européennes marine le pen mais
dont on imagine ce qu'il en pense marine
le pen elle ne veulent ne veut plus
vraiment sortir de l'union européenne et
donc du coup il ya la volonté de
récupérer ces voilà qui grignotent
qu'armand les voix des républicains et
puis il ya aussi la volonté de se
démarquer des manuels macron parce que
donc comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure
entre les l'air emmanuel macron il n'y a
pas non plus énormément à les
différences absolument évidente
ça donne finalement avec cette volonté
de parler de d'immigration de sécurité
c'est un une campagne pendant laquelle
en fait la plupart des candidats que ce
soit michel barnier que ce soit valérie
pécresse xavier bertrand et c'est qu'ils
veulent leurs propres politiques
nationales d'immigration et pour ceux là
réaffirmer la primauté des lois
françaises sur les lois européennes en
matière d'immigration bon le problème
c'est que c'est déjà mondiale à dire que
c'est le cas mais la législation
européenne en matière d'immigration
elle est extrêmement permissive et elle
n'est pas très dense donc en réalité les
états et france notamment sa politique
migratoire c'est la sienne
essentiellement les lois françaises ce
sont elles pour prévoir en fait les
molettes des modalités d'immigration il
ya quelques quelques règles européennes
mais qui en réalité en vraiment sont
extrêmement permissive et laisse
beaucoup beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
aux états michel barnier par exemple ça
a été un des premiers à dire qu'il
voulait faire primer les règles
migratoires français sur européenne bon
ça n'a pas vraiment de sens et puis en
plus de ça
quand on quand on parle de l'immigration
on laisse de côté souvent les questions
que ce soit de regroupement familial ou
d'asile qu'il a sondés droit pour le
coup et sur lesquelles il faudrait
vraiment apporté des modifications à la
fois du droit européen mais aussi la
constitution etc pour y arriver il ya un
autre sujet mais je trouve assez
important dans cette campagne là c'est
la question de la place des juges et de
l'indépendance de la justice on a vu ça
notamment avec la décision du tribunal
constitutionnel polonais il ya quelques
semaines qui a donc créé un tribunal qui
n'est plus indépendant au sens de
l'union européenne et la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et qui à part un
espèce de deux coups politiques affirmer
la primauté de la constitution pour le
ned sur le droit le droit européen hélas
beaucoup en fait de politiques français
alors à droite mais aussi à gauche ans
arnaud montebourg se sont engouffrés
dans cette brèche là pour dire ben oui
voilà vous voyez même le tribunal
constitutionnel polonais dit qu'il faut
faire primer le droit le droit la
constitution nationale sur le droit
européen sauf qu'en réalité ici c'est
pas vraiment un problème de primauté
c'est un problème de d'attitude
vis-à-vis de la justice est indépendante
de l'indépendance de la justice en
france on a un thème récurrent depuis le
début du 20e siècle c'est la question du
gouvernement des juges on a toujours eu
peur un de deux de nos juges en france
et c'est cette thèse qui est développée
au début du 20e siècle elle l'est l'euro
elle est comment dire ce une sorte de
serpent de mer 1 chez les politiques
français qui reçoit beaucoup aujourd'hui
et ceux qui critiquent tout comme au
début du 20e siècle le gouvernement des
juges ou le risque d'un gouvernement des
juges ce sont ceux en fait qui
critiquent le juge lorsqu'il va sur le
terrain des libertés essentiellement
c'est là qu'on va critiquer le convoi
critiqué le juge parce qu'on considère
que ça réduit la marge de manoeuvre du
politique etc marine le pen eric zemmour
arnaud montebourg et c est aussi la
droite de l air sur les premiers à
dénoncer les risques de gouvernement des
juges et donc ils soutiennent en fait le
gouvernement polonais dans cette
démarche-là gouvernement polonais a tout
simplement est tout simplement en train
de détruire sa justice league en train
de détruire commandes l'indépendance des
juges il ya une cohérence en fait
idéologique ici entre ce qui se passe en
pologne et la position de certains en
france atteint pour le candidat en
france
et donc assurer la primauté de la
constitution française sur le droit
européen je vais finir par ça en réalité
c'est pas ça le vrai sujet de ces
candidats là le vrai sujet de ces
candidats c'est diminuer les pouvoirs du
juge c'est contraindre le juge et le
politiser pour que ils suivent la ligne
du parti au pouvoir c'est tout en fait
c'est mettre un terme à l'indépendance
de la justice et aux libertés finalement
et la protection des libertés des
citoyens
faisant 1-1 commentaires vers ce nom oui
alors très très rapidement ça va très
très très très rapidement effectivement
les perspectives de faire sortir la
france du lion du droit européen que ce
soit le droit qui viendraient de la cour
de justice de l'union européenne de la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est un non sens absolu c'est un non
sens absolu c'est vraiment ce sont
vraiment des propositions strictement
politiques qui sont décorrélés de toute
réalité effective en termes de droit si
on s'en tient simplement à
une position et à une analyse juridique
il faut nécessairement concevoir qu'on
ne peut pas on ne peut plus se passer
désormais des apports de l'un et de
l'autre et on voit tout ce que ça a
permis de faire évoluer en terme de en
terme de société en termes d'apport
alors nos hommes politiques de droite
qui sont très sympathiques alors je fais
pas une critique des hommes politiques
nombre de jean-charles vous inquiétez
pas
simplement on voit alors il ya eu
beaucoup d'apports de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme notamment sur les
droits des gardés à vue peut-être que de
quelques hommes politiques de droite ont
eu quelques gardes à vue c'est dans un
passé récent et ont été ravis de se voir
notifier des droits et d'avoir pu
bénéficier de l'assistance effective
d'un avocat à cette occasion donc là
dessus il faut quand même se féliciter
de l'apport de la convention de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme on est
aussi dans un droit qui est constamment
évolutif avec des choses qui doivent
être prises en compte nécessairement
d'aujourd'hui par cette évolution des
choses par exemple alors si on sort des
libertés individuelles et des droits
fondamentaux
nous sommes tous des e-consommateurs
dans le cas du e-commerce est ce ses
droits 2 du e-commerce ils sont gérés au
niveau de l'union européenne parce qu'il
faut qu'une harmonisation lorsque vous
achetez si vous avez si vous achetez à
une société depuis derrière votre
ordinateur à une société allemande
portugaise espagnole vous êtes quand
même content et rassurés de savoir que
un droit uniforme s'appliquera si jamais
vous avez une quelconque difficulté donc
maintenant regarder le droit d'une
manière france stricto franco française
ça me semble être totalement hors cadre
de la société dans laquelle nous vivons
maintenant et bien sûr que alors bien
sûr qu'on peut faire des critiques à
l'europe il y avait réformé peut y avoir
également mais se passer de l'apport du
droit européen aujourd'hui sur tous les
sujets ça me semble être d'un point de
vue juridique totalement impossible
notamment du sanguin sur lesquels kiev
un certain nombre de candidats se pose
tout à fait débattu
des trouve aparté au dernier sujet sur
la cinquième vague du coup vite parce
que c'est inquiétant pour un certain
nombre de maires justement cette
cinquième vague et puis avec cette
question est-ce qu'il faut confier nos
vacciner
[Musique]
catherine arnaud je me souviens que
quand il est là les vagues du coup vie
société c'était très inquiétant pour
vous d avec le confinement dans l'est
dans un certain nombre de quartiers
c'était difficile
difficile d'abord parce que les gens se
sont trouvées hors sociétés et que
certaines sommes plus en plus on est
dépendant de la société dont plus on est
en situation de précarité plus le fait
d'être dans une société qui n'existent
plus parce que c'est quand même ce qu'on
a vécu était était difficile donc
évidemment ça a été davant l'éloignement
après la pauvreté
parce que la provôté ça c'est tomber
très vite sur le dos des ceux qui
avaient des petits boulots qui avait
dont les enfants étaient plus pris en
charge par la collectivité et donc nous
mr eric dumont on a on a à cette époque
là on a géré le quotidien plus que de
gérer le problème de 6 de santé publique
un parce qu'on était quand même dans un
flou artistique sur la santé publique
sur ce qu'il fallait faire ou ne pas
faire et après on a accompagné ces les
efforts de santé et est propre et le
comportement du gouvernement avec la
distribution de masques avec
l'incitation et la mise en place des
vaccinations parce qu'il fallait aussi
qu'on arrive à convaincre le plus grand
nombre je faisais était difficile dans
certains quartiers pour dire ça a été
difficile de mettre en place les valets
les vaccinations oui mais là ce n'était
pas le fait des habitants s'étaient plus
tôt fait de l'organisation un peu
de convaincre les gens de se vacciner
salaire de convaincre les gens de se
vacciner oui bah oui ils écoutent
généralement tout sauf ce qui est
raisonnable donc oui effectivement il
fallu les convaincre de se faire
vacciner avec d'abord la conviction sur
eux et on s'est appuyé à ce moment là
surtout les les supports à la soie
associatif
mais mais mais tous les gens de bonne
volonté des territoires qui est pour
lutter contre les propos des propos
inconsidérés donc on a réussi à faire
vacciner par vagues comme ça les plus
fragiles néanmoins nous sommes de
territoire sur lequel on n'écoute plus
facebook qui que ce soit d'autre et les
propos et les propos peu délirante plus
que laisse plus que la sérieux donc on a
encore des taux de vaccinations qui sont
moindres et on le déplace et du coup on
a des obligations de prise en charge un
peu compliqué mais mais du coup là aussi
on peut s'apercevoir que ça complique la
vie de tous puisque par exemple c gepa
sanitaires sur lequel lavalas c'est un
fait je n'ai pas à dire c'est bien ou
mal mais c'est un fait abbas a
évidemment ça donne beaucoup plus de
contraintes à ceux qui sont pas vaccinés
et qui sont plus éloignés de ce qu'il a
pour la pression des gallagher le risque
que c'est pour les autres mais jamais et
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut confiner les
palais nous vacciner moi je dis il faut
vacciner les non vaccinés mais les
données et peut-être peut-être t elle
après il faudra poser la question est ce
qu'il faut pour le vaccin obligatoire
c'est encore autre chose
mais
il ya un côté au coton les petits on est
vacciné
premier ministre la ministre de la santé
de ce gouvernement a imposé assez
rapidement aux vaccins obligatoires il
avait à cette époque là 6 à mon souvenir
est-ce que ça fait un tollé général 1 or
ça s'adressait aux enfants de 2 mois et
demi c'était peut-être là qu'il fallait
respecter le même si à faire
vous m'aider et là c'est pas tout le
monde a trouvé ce que c'était une
évidence mais oui c'était une évidence
la protection individuelle ne se fait
que par une obligation de protection
collective ça fait des générations qu'on
vit comme ça et on arrive à convaincre
les gens petit à petit que parce que
parce qu'on sait que c'est ensemble
qu'on ce qu'on se défend contre un virus
une bague qui arrive on a quelqu'un on
n'a qu'à regarder l'histoire pourquoi on
vaccine plus contre la variole parce
qu'on a tellement vacciner qu'il n'y a
plus de varier
regardons simplement combien on a été
efficace et
oui nous sommes prêts ce qui
l'intéressé vraiment pas ce qui est
toujours des discours on regarde et
regarde et on s'en sort mieux que les
autres regardez à un moment de dire
regardez les allemands c'est formidable
ils ont un système qui fait qu'au zoo et
puis ils ont eu la vague comme nous
courent après et là on disait regardez
les allemands olala ça va très mal joué
mais nous la valve vient après on va
après l'autriche et l'allemagne c'est
vrai que voilà rien rien afs et 8 ans
sauf sauf sauf en effet la vaccination
avec les libertines sa filiation il est
évident qu'on n'est jamais protégé du
virus hin1 sauf à ce que nous nous
replions tout sur nous mêmes ce qui de
toute façon n'est pas possible alors moi
sur ce sujet là
de toute façon je pense que nous sommes
tous d'accord autour de ce plateau sur
la position avoir par rapport au vaccin
la question que je me pose c'est dans
l'hypothèse où le gouvernement
envisagerait de confiner les
non-vaccinés
sera ce possible sur un plan strictement
juridique alors peut-être que sans race
en avril un avis aussi il va ya il va y
avoir une difficulté à mon avis sur un
plan de l'allant j'ai pas d'avis tranché
là dessus hein c'est vraiment une
réflexion à voix haute que j'ai c'est
est-ce que
discriminer oui une partie si
la vaccination n'est pas obligatoire
est-ce que ce soit sera impossible alors
pour le coup le gouvernement si jamais
la situation sur venir la question
advient est ce qu'il aura outre une
volonté politique la possibilité
juridique de confiner les non vaccinés
je suis pas je suis pas totalement
certains a déclaré vincent le sur
l vaccins obligatoires est ce que c est
juridiquement possible et le confinement
des noms vaccine et l
je suis assez d'accord je vais partager
les comment dire un les doutes
de geoffrey meyer parce que
lorsque il avait été question en plein
coeur de la pandémie de ne confine et
que les personnes âgées au surligneur on
s'était posé la même question est-ce
qu'il ne risque pas d'y avoir ici une
discrimination qui n'est pas justifié
est ce que est ce que notre constitution
le permet très simplement on avait émis
de sérieux doutes par rapport à ça
aujourd'hui donc on pourrait dire que la
question est à peu près la même pour la
question pour l'obligation vaccinale ou
le confinement des non vaccinés en tout
cas pour le confinement des non vaccinés
et j'émettrais les mêmes doutes
maintenant c'est comment dire rien est
impossible le droit aussi certaine marge
de 2,2 comment dire de
manoeuvre et d'interprétation est aussi
le gouvernement s'aventurer sur cette
voie là on ne peut pas préjuger de ce
que dirait le conseil constitutionnel
surtout dans une période où le virus y
ont encore peur etc voilà donc ça c'est
moi je j'ai aussi quelques doutes mais
voilà il faut espérer en fait l'idéal ce
serait de ne pas avoir à mettre en
oeuvre ce genre de mesure
de
les obliger de confiner les gens et est
absolument aberrant que ce soit des
vieux des non vaccinés et c'est qu'on
interdise les lieux de plaisir de
détente les lieux publics tout à fait
d'accord on a quand même le droit de se
promener et d'aller où on veut de qu'on
a interdit aux non vaccinés d'aller d'un
des restaurants très bien qu'on
l'interdise les boîtes de nuit qu'on
interdise les rues les restaurants les
cinémas tout ce qu'on veut très bien
mais la liberté de circuler on va
enfermer les gens m'aiment parce qu'ils
sont pas comme nous mais c est au delà
du droit que ce soit faisable ou pas ça
m'est égal mois a priori sur la notion
même de confinement je pense qu'elle est
assez évolutive aussi aller je pense que
la notion de confinement tel qu'on
l'entend désormais en novembre et de
l'inter c'est plus le confinement
nous avions subi en mars 2000 en mars
2020 mais effectivement même restreindre
dans l'hypothèse où on restreindrait la
liberté de circulation de la liberté
d'aller et venir des personnes qui ne
sont pas vaccinés
pas sur un mode aussi contraignant que
celui que nous avons subie en mars 2020
se poserait quand même in fine et cette
question juridique ce débat sur est-ce
que c'est possible ou non hélas après il
peut y avoir aussi le pas sony terre
soumis à trois vaccins
expliqué qu est quand même la suite
usagers la solution probablement la plus
simple une partie de la population
seulement je pense que ce soit efficace
donc je pense que verseuse à personne ne
sonne ne va s'embarquer dans un truc
aussi compliqué en ayant tout n'étant
pas sûr de l'efficacité des dispositifs
d'autant que c'est une à mon avis une
mesure qui est on l'a présenté tellement
compliqué et délicat tant sur le plan
juridique que politique que l
n'adviendra que si jamais la situation
se dégrade de manière extrêmement forte
et extrêmement extrêmement significative
a priori alors sans être sans faire
partie des 60 millions
d'épidémiologistes en france il ya
encore des solutions à l'heure actuelle
qui permettrait de deux d'aboutir à un
autre résultat notamment par les gestes
barrières notamment par la vaccination
d'une troisième dose et notamment par le
la reprise de bons réflexes que nous
avons peut être perdu en serial voilà en
ces temps un peu moins troublé que ce
que nous avons connu les autres maladies
transmissibles les bronchiolites les
grippes reprennent alors
qu'il ya une preuve qu'on a baissé la
garde donc ça peut aussi ça doit être un
signe hébert et relevant lagardére
faisons attention dans nos comportements
quotidiens merci infiniment merci aux
cookies entraîneur nous merci beaucoup
je ressors johnny geoffrey meyer merci
vincent couronne merci à canto des
merguez loin de nous maintenant et à
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
poste merci
[Musique]